okay hi everyone this is a orphan
language design review talking about
machine learning for version 13.3
and uh
the advance of things in the world means
that we've got all kinds of exciting
things happening in machine learning
uh image synthesize how's it doing
what that's in proto should be working
if you want to test it
so this still not it doesn't have
service credits so if you use
Christopher packaging okay so let's see
okay
yeah I'm just using open AI so this
still has this thing in place if you if
you if you have your key you you can use
it otherwise I can demo it this is going
to use service credits as soon as we set
it up set this up but we're going to
provide access to other models than this
one right yeah there's a method option
which I don't know if I have actually
exposed that because right now we only
support of an AI but we will support
different Services as soon as they are
we hook up against other apis but we'll
also support something that is a
downloadable thing on our own site right
a small model that's downloadable for us
right yeah we don't have a small motor
convert get with good quality but we are
looking for a decent one to to add to
the pool yeah I mean these are all
options on the table not on the table
option on the on the pipeline
it seems that that space is evolving
quite drastically as we speak yeah we
have a good idea okay so I just I just
entered my credentials
and it took them
so now what's going to happen
there's a Crocodile yep
so
this is like a reasonable I mean to uh
until we have service credit this is
kind of decent in a sense that you don't
um you can enter This only once and then
it will you can use all the services
with that authentication so right kind
of the fire and forget
if you want a bigger image you can say
image size or medium or
an evil LOL
[Laughter]
have you been reading lots of prompts
or sort of what people a bit I mean for
these things yeah yeah a little bit I
mean I'm not an expert but um
uh
should be called not prompt engineering
prompt hack let's let's try let's try
something there's a different endpoint
which is a variation
so maybe after with the the Matisse one
you can take this and put it back in
image synthetize and say listen to that
is that image comma five for example
and get five variations of this one
the model decides of the sometimes more
variations sometimes like kind of bigger
variations
I really really want to say getting data
from but I don't want to say retrieving
data if that's what it's doing
or is it actually running at that point
no he's waiting for the API to answer
yeah we could say retrieving
okay or waiting for if that's what it's
doing
because maybe the actual transfer time
is very small so we don't want to make
it seem like it has to spend all its
time retrieving the data
okay makes sense waiting for
waiting for results from
okay so if I say text synthesize
oops
okay so what why don't I get more here
uh we need to decide here what to put
the maximum number of tokens the default
one is 16. I put it at 50 is somewhat
arbitrary you can say one more item to a
stop character let's get to a stop token
watch it I mean on on the on track EBT
for example it runs until it hits a stop
token yes
correct but in this case you are paying
per token so
it's
um why didn't that work
oh no no that's we use we use that
argument for
um different variations
and
so how do I but we need a way oh yeah
yeah sorry yeah
yeah we have a way it's it's like if you
say Max item goes to whatever you want
like 1000 it's a temporary name for the
option we could say I use box items we
have Max item Max iterations we could
introduce a new symbol
I think that that should be the um you
know I would have thought the second
argument yeah I don't know I mean this
is the second element is the variations
so if you say I don't think that's right
I don't think that's right because I
think I think it's either going to run
to the stop token
by default should run to the stop token
I think it's what people expect I mean
these won't go on forever right they get
to a stop token don't they hopefully
I mean yeah
what
statistically they do
we could say one thousand to be sure I
don't know but then we should have we
can have a Max items option but so long
as it's not usually hit and so long as
it usually is limited by the by the stop
I keep on saying codon but I mean tokens
yeah yeah
um pretty good idea though that's kind
of what it is
yes yes yes yes yes
there are a limited number of ideas in
the pool in the universe
um
okay
uh
you know it is very amusing the way that
this is you know it's sequentially
generated so what it said firstly has no
choice but to say secondly
but it doesn't know it's going to say
secondly and yet yet we all think that
it has a global plan
yeah
anyway it's true uh okay
are you sure that we want to do
variations being the second argument and
by the way what other arguments are
there can I see the docs for this yeah
sure
source
so there's one other use case just just
before we move to the second argument
which is the impacting
where you can give a transparent image
or in an image and a mask you see the
the third case
and a description of what you want where
the transparent part is and that will
fill it in
so in a sense
the notion of a pattern
here is transparency in the image
or something
is a missing thing here it's like it's
like in easily you like in painting
right
but so if I were to take
um
uh anyway
it's not too bad
is there any way of getting higher
resolution yeah image size is small
medium large you can say large
if you like it you can even put that in
and say image search large to get a
larger like higher resolution but it's
kind of a super resolution
let's try it
let's say running
running computation or something
well
that's pretty Sinister creature
doubling as a leopard while it's out
it's even truly frolicking but yeah it's
hardly frolicking but then wolves
probably don't frolic
uh but I like the super resolution stuff
that's really nice
hey is that strictly speaking super
resolution in a sense because it's
really you know it can change whatever
it wants to change but uh
but for many purples this is fine enough
right nice okay let me just look at some
of the other arguments here
I'm keeping these
um purposefully simple because we don't
want to tie tie our heads with the
design which is to uh to tight or on an
API that will change no I agree
um
parameters in a sock what's in a sock
well text image and mask so I'm hiding
the the in painting
um
if you don't put provide a transparent
image
I'm hiding the impainting in the
association because who knows right now
we have like three things that you can
pass you know maybe in two months we
have like five things that you can pass
the API
yeah and when do we get 3D images
uh
okay this is really cool
let's just make sure we get more apis
supported
yeah and together with the ability to
have at least some small model that's
local
yeah yeah we're working on all those
fronts actually at the same time so um
yeah
uh
so this is very much the same thing
except that
yeah this is a kind of a simpler design
in a sense
um it has more parameters I'm exposing
two which are the same that we expose in
our class net decoder which is
temperature and top probability cutoff
which is a the top the nucleus sampling
uh again just to keep the design simple
this stuff is related to sampling so
it's very likely that it's going to be
available in other apis
okay
random seating I put it as a future
because it's something that I really
really hope uh openai is going to add
mid Journey has it for the image API
in order to be able to to retrieve the
same results yeah right if you call the
API twice so
you know I'm not convinced about the
second argument here
it's going to save a bit of bandwidth
and if you have a long token
a long prompt
is also going to save you money because
you're gonna send it over only once
okay well these things will be
experimental I'm not certain that that's
the right thing
I think this should be automatic or all
this Max items thing
okay an automatic basically means go to
the stop token unless it's more than
let's say a thousand or something
and all should just mean go to the stop
token whatever happens
and we're not responsible if you end up
with a you know an AI and a loop
that's charging you money
does that make sure
cool
okay
okay are we looking at this now are we
going to look at this separately the
chat stuff
um I mean if you want we can look at
this stack briefly now and
um
basically we've been meeting with design
to decide a bit what to do here and most
of all how to
in integrate these with chat notebook so
yeah design is is moving fast right now
the idea here is that we are keeping
these as a kernel back end for other
functionalities
so we are focusing on like conversion
capabilities you can extract a list of
messages from the chat object you can
use the create shot on the list of
messages to create a new chat object so
it can be used for you know extraction
conversion and handling the all the API
part in a in an OPAC way so you can you
can kind of abstract away the specific
service you are using
right
um
okay let's keep going image identify new
network
great
that's pretty pathetic accuracy well oh
we are not using this is a much larger
collection of classes than the standard
stuff like imagenet
okay this is why it's lower
it's this is meant to be uh useful for
kind of like a feeder extraction other
applications so we we moved to a model
which is much more generalizable because
it's been trained with noisy data and in
a teacher student way
okay so it's kind of interesting
what's the performance goal by default
quality
I mean we typically do quality I think
that's right yeah
but that's only six you said eight
percent slower
yeah it's like not significantly slower
but okay
the big problem is the first use of
image identifier which is absurdly slow
how do we speed that up I just
I realized that there was one one
download downloadable packlet that was
um that continentology that was Steve
using it was never never actually pushed
to production was still using some wdx
format so uh I updated that to to get
you know better alignment data and move
that to a Max so that he's cutting like
half a second
why is this slow this is downloading the
network itself I think
and I don't know why this is actually
failing for you that's the dude who he's
put in there
um
shall I try it again but but okay so how
do we not I mean I already complained
about the speed thing before but we
didn't find that
I mean we have I mean there's a bunch of
things that need to happen the first
time you run it this you you need to
load the mxnet library and then that I
mean the old our packages now are
mxified
and and now with this thing that I hope
it will be much
sooner it push to production soon
because the chocolate we're gonna cut
another half second from the from the
another half second we're dealing with
it's 30 seconds
no it was never 30 seconds for me if you
already have a network downloaded it is
on my machine is like three to four
seconds
framework first of all
okay is all the stuff that needs to be
downloaded in the CDN
um you mean downloading the network
yeah it's the network of the CDN
I have no idea I mean that's using
resource object
we can check yes okay uh I I think most
of that stuff is in CDN but I don't know
I remember we had a discussion about
like putting the the models used by
internal functions on a fast track
well let's just check that that happened
yeah
every
let's double check yeah
yeah okay but I assume when you say that
it's low it's not just a download that
is uh or is or you're factoring in the
the download as part of that
no I mean so long as I can see an up you
know as long as I can see a progress
monitor I'm okay
well I mean you had a progress mode
yeah I did
okay
here's a question to you I was what's
that
no I just tried to to run it on my
prototype and I and it doesn't fail but
maybe you have an older prototype uh I'm
downloading a new one two to figure it
out the phone
okay everybody says try to build from
last week it took 10 seconds to download
and get the result but was all that time
spent downloading Avery or was it spent
okay but so the the time when it was
invisibly going off and grinding was
minimal
yes that's what we have to measure and
Stefan needs to make sure that we
actually measure that
right okay and you know if it's more
than about a second of grinding that's
no good
right after after the download
okay
so Julio do you expect it to be more
than a second of I mean what's it doing
afterwards yeah I think 30 seconds
it's too long
well it means that we can't use it in an
API cascading there is the
the package where the Imaging file is
defined which is very small and that's
super fast to load yeah then that
triggers neural networks which in turn
triggers mxnet link
okay and then you need to load the and
this is just to to get the code
um
I mean so we need to figure out how to
make that
more streamlined
what is the what is the issue all those
things are maxified right
yeah
it's just that you need to load the
library memory
which Library
like uh let me see for example if I quit
and I do a get of mxnet Link
how much time does it take let's profile
it and find out what it's actually doing
because I don't think this is right
it doesn't take that time to load a
dynamic Library
if that's what it's doing
okay so getting MX link is like 0.65
seconds
I can
I I mean let's not do waste time here I
can give you a notebook I I did this
several times I have like already stuff
set up to to take the exact time of each
each piece I can send you an email with
all the all the details but more more
relevant is let's fix it
okay
okay I mean I you know and Stefan could
you please make sure that this really is
done and not
something where we just have a test that
says 10 seconds is okay because it's
really not
make sense
okay all right let's keep going I have a
question for you if I want to take
something like gpt2
or a simple image model and I want to
add noise to all of the weights how can
I do that
how to do it uh
you could extract all the arrays and
then do a natural place part
with a modified yeah and how do I find
the arrays
arrays like information I'm trying the
syntax now information let's start with
the net for example which is more not
model
yeah I'm just pasting some code now in
the chat erase
okay so if you replace that with
something
with noise
and then you do not replace part of a
net model it should work
okay so you're saying if I take for
example let's say I take gpt2
this is nice although I couldn't
possibly figure it out for myself
um
yeah we try to be super transparent in
the framework so like arrays and the um
like Parts same as layers
so you can
you can just replace them and and
extract them with the same part syntax
sorry so I mean here again this will
give the array so I just have to map
over this adding noise and then do a net
replace exactly I don't know
right yeah yeah you can do net net
replace part if you call if you call the
net model plan net then you can do
Network place part net
comma information net arrays it would be
a no op but it it basically is doing a
replacement
that's cool it's very cool
right that's what I wanted for
um
okay
uh it might be good to show that as a as
an example
noted I'm going to add it in
let's replace part probably
yep
so it's a little Annoying always that uh
we need to decide what to do with
information maybe we need an information
section on symbols and support
information like in scope or something
because yeah it's difficult to document
this stuff in the information page
yeah we don't want to do that yeah um
maybe it wants to be a section at the
end of the details
yeah what is like options I mean yeah
right like we're doing options like
we're doing the full options stuff
we have a section about information
there and then we could have
that's his scope has subsections right
yeah yeah I was thinking about that
it doesn't but
no no scope it does in in many pages oh
scope yeah scope I mean the examples yes
right I thought you meant details sorry
yeah actually I tried to sell this idea
to Roger if we could have subsection in
details and options
um
okay
well I think this is a separate
discussion but but yes we definitely
need a way to document information
uh I mean at the very least we could
have a section that is purely textual
that just lists
you know I I would say the way to do it
is list something like information of
dot dot dot comma arrays
so in other words you have a table where
you can visibly see immediately that
it's an information a table about
information
did you understand what I'm saying no no
sorry
what is in the table information of
natural arrays and then the results no
no it just says all the explanations
there's no point in saying that or you
could say information of net comma
arrays and then what we've done this is
I mean it's kind of like when you have
an object with string arguments it's the
same but you have to use information
here
yes but I'm just saying when you
document it don't just write a table
that says arrays blah thing blah thing
blah because nobody will oh no yes yes
you want to repeat it every line
information yes so that it reinforces
the idea that you really really have to
use information right right and
similarly I would not I think it's going
to be super tedious Stephen we did a
couple of attempts like that
I think it'll be okay I think it's more
important to communicate it than it is
to be tedious than not to be tedious so
to speak
I try it but I mean you definitely for
the sub values you definitely want to
list them as net of blah not just blah
you know what I'm saying
yeah I get it but that's usually what we
say in the line before the table I I
know that I don't think it's enough
I don't think it's enough I think it's a
mistake I've been very confused by it
many times
we can pick this up in a documentation
meeting I'm telling you I don't think
it's the right thing
people browse documentation they need to
see the explicit form
and if we needed to we could have
something where we make this a smaller
font or something
get what I'm saying
um
all right let's keep going here
what is this that model dramatic speed
up what on of what
of inference or what or of loading
we rebuild it using an optimize Intel
Library
makes it faster
okay
across the board some layers are a lot
faster some like in general is uh it's
considerably faster like it goes from
like uh 10 to like 100 percent
okay that's cool
okay pie torch now working for Netflix
uh yeah no yeah I I would have wished
that the thing is pi torch doesn't
deliver on the Standalone uh formats so
they have something like on an X but
um it it doesn't I mean when you can
export to that it works but not many
models can like without massaging or
stuff you know we need to dig deeper in
the stock you don't you cannot export
with the Sunderland model why why do why
we mean why is it a problem we discussed
that about hugging phase because the
default workflow when you distribute a
Python's model
is that you link to some python code
that you have to run locally to create
something in memory and then load in the
weights
which comes in a parameter file so this
is extremely cumbersome to represent in
an external thingy because it's not
something that you just you know point
in library to something and you run the
code no but can't we can't we replicate
that behavior by running using a python
link and so on
yeah yeah I mean we can but is is
something that requires you know is what
do you put in that external object is a
much more complicated design because
it's not you're not pointing it to some
binary you are pointing it to like a
repo
and what what what do you run in that
reboot well I mean it sounds like
it's like a packlet
yeah basically yes they distribute
networks and Sparkletts right the
important thing for us is that we can
put in the neural net repository we can
put models that are net external object
models
how they work inside so long as they
work reliably I don't think it's so
important how they work inside
I mean I agree
but the thing is I I was really hoping
for something that could effortly you
know convert Python's model to quickly
access thousands of them
just because we have a certain standard
for doing software engineering does not
mean the rest of the world does oh
you know okay I get your point it's
probably much Messier
but if we can provide something where it
will at least work even if it has to go
you know grinding through some you know
loading this uh you know running this
Etc et cetera et cetera that's still a
win yeah but wait wait that means that
you need to have your external evaluator
set up on your system with python
these days
even the amount of error I get every
time I miss configure it no
oh maybe no I don't know I mean maybe
can you talk to other people because I
thought we were shipping some version by
default
okay wasn't there where were the Sheep
uh the python interpreter with the with
the system okay
that that is what I believe was planned
I mean Todd would know about it
okay there's some recent DC meeting
okay yeah that would simplify things
greatly
right I think it's going to be I mean
Ricardo knows about it I think
um and Todd knows about it
okay
nowadays I can just bang on Ricardo's
door and ask him so here's an excuse me
what's that yeah because I'm in Rome
again so yeah yeah yeah okay fair enough
okay
the uh
I won't pick any winning Rome jokes
I don't even know what they'd be anyway
never mind okay
um Okay so
net State object this is a very nice
concept that we had
um
it was able to basically convert I mean
all our layers are immutable
this thing I was able to convert uh
recursion layers so into into
intermutable things so you could
basically do the efficient thing
very very easily you just wrap you know
wrap net State object around the network
but contains uh
layers with recursion and then you can
just keep applying the same thing over
and over and it will carry all the
states inside you don't have to do any
modification any unfolding any tracking
the thing is this thing was never like
updated for uh two things that are
present in Transformers which is uh you
remember we saw we look at that sequence
in the exposition there I don't remember
underscore the one that is basically
telling you the position of a token in
the sequence and the other one that is
important is the attention layer so now
we are updating both of them to work
inside netstate object and the end
product of that is that you could say
net State object of the gpt2 for example
and then you the result of that you
could you can get the efficiency where
it doesn't have to be evaluated over the
whole sequence every time I think it's
very neat it's just one command to go
from the state waitlist to stateful
I'm still a little bit confused give me
an example how you'd use it like for in
gpt2
okay let's see imagine you you want to
you your blog sentence
um what was it like the interesting
about the eyes
the best thing too the best thing about
the AI is the ability too yeah so you're
passing these to the model and the model
is generated in one token then you need
to take the longer sequence and pass it
back yep but the but the model has
already the what is causal and it has
already computed
on up to those tokens you just needs the
extra bits
yes yeah in terms of new data but it
needs also the all the old data because
all the attention layer inside we are
doing the remixing
so you can you know you can do a
trade-off if you save
the intermediate product of all the
attention layers and this is what
Netflix object is doing yeah then you
can just apply net State object to the
single new token
and this is why you get it faster right
but so when we actually have things in
the neural net repository are we
planning to insert net State object
things into them somehow
but we we can show it at this point I
mean if it was an asset object is that
literally a one-liner so
yeah well so you can't distract them
what do we do yeah so how do we turn
gpt2 into a mutable net State object
kind of creature
well you just you just wrap it you just
wrap the net set object Around the Net
model so if you open the documentation
page from that let's say the object you
see you see how it works is actually
quite easy
okay we see the first example for
example is net of a basic recurrent
layer you know you really shouldn't use
that science for these you really should
use square brackets
okay what I think okay okay I agree
about these but I have one point to make
about this stuff we had this stuff like
right composition and left composition
and if this came up talking about data
set and piping operations and that's a
very nice Syntax for piping operation
but we never show it in the
documentation because it's you know to
like kind of too exotic
I mean people know it's like
yeah I agree so there's kind of a
balance between showing too much and not
showing full stuff we have
so it will be forever new you never show
it but anyway yeah anyway
so you see in this case it's just one
line the the the state object is just an
exit object wrapped around Net and then
you just keep applying it
that's cool so could I do this right now
I mean if I say no this is not all in
Prototype we have a the positions
emerged and because we have a new
developer and we're training him on this
so I mean like this is
working the branch but but like the
example I had of netlist
um Nest list of um uh you know gpt2
applied to a sentence adding words and
so on it's saying that with this that
would happen much faster
exactly exactly is it the same
do I type the same thing with Nest list
applied to I mean how would I do that
well no because you don't need to join
it yeah it wasn't a nest list where you
were joining in the input you were
joining the um the past with the present
yes yes in this case you can do the same
without the string drawing
okay so it's still gonna be a nice list
because you want to show all the
intermediate if you want to show the
intermediate steps otherwise just just
mess yep but that's really nice
okay
yeah I think I mean this this week I I
kind of forgot that you had this and and
while I was talking to Mateo we realized
that actually it was just a matter of
exposing State because we have these are
not really States yeah but we can
generalize the concept of state which is
like an input port or an output Port but
it's kind of a side port you can use it
in the net graph if you if you want but
but by default it doesn't show up in
input or output because it's like it's
wrapped around yeah but if we if this is
very powerful concept and a net State
object is basically just making this
stateful so it I think it follows nicely
also the way you explain it
sounds good
okay
the underground tree so this is maybe an
actual tree exactly we look at this uh a
few months ago I
I brought it to kind of a state where
it's kind of uh it's it's working well
uh I added a lot of stuff around three
so I'm also meeting with Ian to see what
can be folded back into three
uh because you see there are like new
um new ways of doing edges and new
layouts you can do circular layouts for
example
right
oh yeah I mean these things should be in
tree for sure exactly this is what I'm
saying yeah we want to
definitely this should be in tree
those are nice
I mean the real test is when you have
significant uh data in each Leaf which
you're starting to have here
that and also when you have a lot of
leads
right well but which tree has the
solution mechanism right which
presumably you're inheriting
I'm just calling tree with a special you
do understand
no no
yeah I I haven't used that in practice
but uh I've seen it I'm sure you can no
no I I I I see what what it's doing
hopefully that will align something
huh
I'll try to try another tree
okay I didn't know it was on by default
basically I thought it was on by default
what if you go to a thousand or
something like really big
but
no I mean you'll see the the illusion at
a particular node
or maybe is when you have a single node
with a lot of yeah that's what it is
okay I'm just surprised we're not seeing
any Illusions here but maybe that's just
the nature of a random tree
that it tends to broaden well yeah it
would be extremely rare that you get all
the children on a single note
but yeah
right but you should make sure that you
can appropriately inherit that and that
your Styles don't collide with that
illusion mechanism
I mean ideally you want to backboard all
these Styles into
uh into tree itself as much as possible
right
okay so here this is like the initial
initial we started looking at all these
statistical functions in uh in an
attempts to kind of uh a kind of take
ownership like slowly but steadily so
the the first thing is uh is going to be
if you scroll up
where you have data
uh you see that in the possible form of
data r
you just you're seeing the the beginning
of it you need to scroll like a little
bit more down
Yep this one here so you see we are
basically making it compatible with
predict and classify in terms of yeah
great so the we we have a lot more like
the we had all the syntaxes ready for
like data set and associations but
there's we need to have some more
thought
in term of how this
um has an effect on model specification
and variable specification because this
stuff was like uh
um like series like um and dissolve
where you give the function and also the
list of variables which doesn't make
much sense with Association in data set
so um instead of rushing this we're
trying to make a sort of design but you
know for the time being we have
everything built out and as soon as we
decide on a way on a way to do it uh and
then then we are going to start
basically
um overhauling all the other all these I
mean type setting make it like a like
modern modern type setting with like
Association properties kind of like
bringing these into like modern times
but by the way but yeah something
something and this maybe is not for this
meeting it's more for the user
assistance meeting is you know when I
Mouse over a thing like this I would
really like to get some kind of
autocomplete that shows me the
properties I can compute from it
the properties well I mean you know
there's some sub values here aren't
there
yeah this is also something that uh we
we I thought again while I was dealing
with the chat object the fact that we
have
okay in this case
you have you can pass a value or pass a
property
I don't love the the fact that they use
the same way to to get it done well
information is our way of doing
properties exactly
because I mean in this case it's safe
because properties are always strings
and right right now this thing takes
only uh
um
only like numbers but what about
categorical variables yeah no I know I
know so maybe we should go more towards
an information based thing than
grandfather in the the few sort of
string properties that are done with sub
values right now
they're not a few if you scroll up to
the details section you'll see well it's
passed on the space of all possible
strengths yeah yeah that's true okay so
you see this is here something else
yeah I think that there are lots of
things to modernize about these
functions you know including these you
know so at those days they often come in
threes like if you wanted the values we
needed to produce the values if we
wanted it to look good we needed to have
something that's right now we have
associations and all these kinds of
things exactly which we didn't
you know there are other things that
that we're coming to
you know it's it's it's like
this set of properties here it's like
getting an A La Carte menu you can get
your you can make your own dish by
combining
each ingredient and that's fine to have
an A La Carte kind of menu but I think
we need some standard reports
effectively no I agree like anovar is a
none of a table is a standard report
which now we have a nice way of dealing
with with data sets exactly yes this
could be like we typically call it
summary
yeah I think I think that that's that's
part of what we need here because like
if you think in terms of workflow that's
what you want to arrive at that first
small set of items is probably what
you're going to use all the time then
there's the a la carte for someone that
wants to really you know special needs
Etc
of course I have a new a new strange
thing that we need to worry about for
these summary boxes and so on which is
the uh linguistic serialization of the
summary boxes
a new and different thing we have to
worry about
okay I see what you mean here
yeah well that's kind of we we have
output form yeah which is uh
how it renders
we we should start reasoning you know if
our output form should be not just you
know fitted model uh open close brackets
dots doing that but uh
output outperformance
yes that yeah and and I mean that is
very important because you know you
don't want the full form of the summary
box
in in a scripting environment I do love
the way that these Concepts you know
output form is invented
okay so that is a bit Goofy well when
when it's literally what it is which is
a bit ugly but if you do output form of
a net for example you should see
something more like uh like very like
aligned or something like that
yeah so this just tells you the number
of layers yeah but you know this is an
extreme but my point was that maybe
these four years while I'm seeing the
input form the input form is a giant
mess exactly so but these things should
kind of grow maybe slightly not too much
to be still kind of reasonable in a
terminal environment but also contain
enough information to be parsed
right I mean it is amusing that we're in
2023 and things that we built in 1988
for terminals are still relevant but
that's yeah
uh well
well you know terminals are still here
Rebels are still in here yeah I know
Rebels are here
okay let's just take a look at some of
these
what is the output from pose estimation
uh it's a list of uh sorry what type of
objects we don't have any kind of
symbolic pose representation no
unfortunately not it's just a list of
points at this point sorry okay
um
is anchor-free object detection is that
relevant for image cases
um
yeah I mean the end result is going to
be the same is is just a different model
under the hood
so in the end you still get uh you still
get boxes out
okay
and these are relevant for OCR I mean
this one
is something we're expecting to use for
the um yeah exactly exactly
okay the the the current models best
models are pretty heavy so we are
training something in-house to be kind
of more small and fast on on a mobile
environment
yeah yeah that's good
what was the time scale for that to be
finished
I was hoping I was hoping to wrap it up
and for like like at the beginning of
this year but what I want to see hoping
for existing models too to be kind of
good or small but yeah we we something
like a month ago uh we are using it to
train a new developer so it's kind of
going a bit slower than if like medium
is
used to train the new developer yeah
yeah
we can do it in the AI and the AI Trends
both ways yeah exactly I mean we we have
like people training AI is uh
exactly right good the Roblox whatever
yeah yes
uh okay stable diffusion that will that
be a reasonable sort of uh
you know downloadable yeah this is what
we hope for so right now we we just
wrapped up a model which is very nice
it's called clip which is basically
using Transformer to do
um
I don't know if I show this to you I
think I want to show Roger and Shady uh
I mean are you you're familiar with the
classical uh classification you have a
soft Max at the end and you have to pick
a class yep but now with the you know
you can you know we have powerful
embeddings for images and sentences
so and that kind of a different way like
an alternative take on classification
is that you compute the embedding for
one image
and then using you know one of those
multimodal uh architectures you also
compute embedding for a bunch of
sentences you know like a like a a nice
bird with like you know red feathers
eating it warm yeah it and then you can
compute the distance between the these
embeddings and this is kind of a
different take but I think is very
interesting because you're not limited
to a number of classes I mean you can
still fall back because if you if you
compute the embedding against a thousand
classes then uh you can pre-compute it
and then fall back on the classical uh
soft Mass thing but you can be a lot
more inventive in in how you classify
stuff how are you combining the
embeddings for the different you know
the bird eating the worm Etc et cetera
et cetera
with with the with the image one yeah
the the model is trained to produce
embeddings with the same dimensionality
let's say like a thousand Dimension so
then you just do the cosine distance
between uh the the image one and all the
textual ones and you find out which one
is is the closest
but how are you how are you mixing
together an image that has let's say
multiple animals in it
how do you make the embedding associated
with each animal
no you don't I mean the image gets a
single embedding so yeah that's up to
the model what it says I mean this is
still for classification not really for
object detection
okay so you kind of describe the full
image
no no parts of the image what's
automatic speech recognition as opposed
to manual speech recognition oh no
that's the name of the task is speech to
text okay fine
and this is a nice nice model but those
works like it can
um also works with other languages uh
we're testing this is nice we are going
to push a bit on uh on Audio models I
also want to do text to speech after
this yeah so how many languages I mean
our existing speech
recognizes only English I believe
is that true
I believe so
yeah be nice to have multilingual and
what's natural language OCR
that's that's that's more modest to do
basically nice
[Music]
do we yet have handwriting
I don't know this is not in track in our
team
okay we are kind of like doing kind of a
Plumbing here sometimes providing
networks and stuff like that fair enough
all right good stuff I should run along
to something else here but this is great
this is lots of lots of nice stuff here
okay thank you
all right
okay let me just check one thing and
then um
great okay see you okay bye for now bye